yesterday the white house press
secretary she said some hilarious stuff
i literally can't stop watching this
video obviously the inflation number
coming in at 8.5
that's wild here in the united states
but right before the number got
published the press secretary was asked
what exactly is gonna happen when it
gets announced what is going to be the
attribution for why the number's so high
listen to what she had to say
so because of the actions we've taken to
address uh putin the putin price type we
are in a better place than we were last
month but we expect march cpa cpi
headline inflation to be extraordinarily
elevated due to putin's price hike and
we expect a large difference between
core and headline inflation reflecting
the global disruptions in energy and
food markets so chlorine inflation
doesn't include energy and food prices
uh headline inflation does and of course
we know that core inflation you know
energy the impact of energy of course on
oil prices gas prices we expect that to
uh continue to reflect what we've seen
uh the increases be over the course of
this invasion
that literally can't be real putin's
price hike what does he control the
prices at the grocery store is he the
one at the gas pump going ahead and
changing the prices no this is absurd we
already saw 7.9 percent inflation before
vladimir putin even thought about
thinking about invading ukraine now of
course putin's not a good dude but it's
also not the reason why america has
historic inflation and the fact that
politicians the press secretary and the
media continue to repeat these stupid
absurd lines putin's price tag just
means they think that the american
people are dumb well guess what we're
not dumb and we know that vladimir putin
didn't cause the inflation it's
undisciplined monetary and fiscal policy
and politicians would have a lot more
trust with the american people if they
simply came out and said hey we did what
we had to do to mitigate short-term pain
this is the trade-off that we made we're
going to address it now and bear with us
as we get it under control a lot of
people would say you know what that
sounds pretty reasonable but when they
start yelling and screaming about
putin's price hike
all we keep thinking is no y'all dumb
inflation's here because of the
decisions you made not cause anything
that putin did now anything that happens
in the future could prices go higher
because of things he did absolutely but
it's about time that we stop with all
the extremism it's the fact that we
don't need to have this divisive
language stop trying to blame it on
dictators around the world we made
decisions that we had to make just go
ahead and own it inflation's high the
american people are suffering let's get
it under control and stop with the
nonsense quite literally the financial
future of tens of millions of people are
counting on it and if we don't actually
address the problems then we're gonna be
in a worse and worse position over the
coming years hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time